okay
so let me start by thanking because that
was by the next extraordinary piece of
documentary if I may say first my
personal impression the impression of
being having being able to concentrate
in only half an hour
all the issues that are concerned with
uh this debate let's call it a debate
between the receiving countries and the
people that come from other countries
and try to cross the borders
uh there are many many
suggestions in your documentary let me
start from my own angle if you allow me
the model
my end goal is
the European Union I am an official
European union and fellow here
and the European Union was mentioned
several times in your documentary
sort of a present and absent
although what we have seen represents
very much similar situation in other
parts of the world but let's concentrate
on why the European Union is an actor
and actually is an actor by presence and
accents I will try to be very brief on
that but it seems to me important while
I was starting I opened the Treaty of
European Union in front of me
and I will start by reading out the
first sentence of Article 2 on that
treaty that says that the union is
founded on the values of respect for
human dignity Freedom democracy equality
the rule of law and respect for human
rights including the rights of person
belonging to minorities
what we have seen here is a direct
challenge to this expression of values
I see the challenges on several on
several aspects
the first challenge is about
the safety of these people
at Sea because this is an island and we
know that there is an ongoing tragedy in
the Mediterranean not only in that part
of the Mediterranean also in the Aegean
area a lot of refugees are dying trying
to cross from the Turkish costs to the
Greek Islands for example
so this is about
international law and shared values of
all the world all the states of the
world
there is a clear
the an existent
law of the sea
since at least
150 2 200 years
that puts the Safeguard of Life at sea
at the top of every kind of action in
the sea so it when somebody is safe at
Sea that person must be brought to the
uh to the mainland
and
protect it
that has been the civilization for all
the countries in the world what we are
seeing and there is some perception here
Beyond this lip service to saving lives
there is always a sentence that refers
to but saving lives but you have to do
this you have to do that this but
represents actually a refrain from
implementing those principles of uh
but Lord understanding of what should be
the protection of life
the second element is the element that I
perceived in this in this documentary
is the separation
between the human being
and its his or her rights
many of the interviews focused on the
belonging to a group
if you belong to a certain group then
you are welcome if you do not belong to
a shirt to another to that group you are
no longer one
that belonging uh it is not clear who
should decide on what that belonging
means but certainly that requirement or
conditions to belonging is in breach of
the values of respect of human dignity
equality rule of law and respect for
human rights why because human rights
are individual human rights
and respect for human dignity is the
respect of the Dignity of each
individual not only if they are part of
a wider group be it religious or
national
and the third element and I will stop
here
and the third element is the conflict
between interests
it is interesting from this documentary
that there are two levels of interests
in competition here
on the one hand we hear
certain interveners stating that there
is an interest for Malta and for the
European countries to have more and
better immigration because we need
skillful and even unskilled labor forces
so we need these people to move to our
countries at the same time the interest
that interest is opposed by those we
heard that that make
coincide the
interest of the country with the
security
means sealing the borders
there is a an interesting question which
is asked by one of the interviewers why
the
warships that are crossing the
Mediterranean in front
that are preventing that the weapons are
smuggled into Libya that has a terrible
Civil War ongoing they do not save
people at Sea that was the question
well the answer May lie in other
interviewers that have said that what
they are interested in is protecting the
country meaning
creating a hard border separating that
country from the rest
this is not only in the Mediterranean
you may have an Eco on what happens in
this country and in other countries in
the world
so about I will stop here I detected
three these three possible lines of of
exchange or in any event these are my
comments at this time
yeah for uh for me as you as you might
have realized this is a documentary that
uh we as a way because I didn't do the
documentary just by myself I did with
both your injury which is a great
colleague that's a very good friend of
mine uh we tried to uh
show something different that is in the
in the published discussion when we talk
about migration and refugees we usually
have this something that I also explored
in my work in the past are very
emotional uh image of migrants so
usually when we read that for example on
a newspaper about migrants we read when
they arrive and when they are drawn we
never read about migrants about their
life what are they doing in Europe about
the Detention Center the the only way
for
these human beings to be somehow to find
some someone interested their life is
when they finally arrive to Europe and
we usually call them an invasion or
where they don't arrive because
unfortunately
they're true and the idea of this
documentary was to work on two different
levels on one level was to show the
migrant and they would like them to come
back on this definition because with a
discussion previously and this
interesting also to talk a bit about
what we talk about when we talk about
migrants refugees Assyrian singers we
should never forget that first of all
they are human beings
so the idea was to show these human
beings not as
uh
people coming from another planet but
just as other human beings like everyone
else in the documentary in the past in
my documentaries I was inevitably also
because of the context that the
documentaries were realized that were
refugee camps focusing a bit more on
their condition now I had the idea to
put them at the same level with all the
other people that was contribute and
then the most important part of the
documentary is to focus on the effects
that the perception that we developed in
the last 11 years since 2011 when the
so-called ARA spring started then we had
all these new phenomenon of
arrivals reaching Europe it's uh how
this perception actually had a very
strong development in the political life
and then on the social perception that
we live in Europe you can see this in
the documentary in different ways there
is something that at some point Eric
woolly say he mentioned that uh
if actually the African population will
decide to truly invade Europe there
would be one to 1.2 billion people this
would be impossible to stop and I think
this
this sentence what you say is very
important because it gives us an image a
clear image of how wrong is our public
discussion about this phenomenon we
continue to stick to this idea of
invasion of uh something that is going
to change our culture because we are
going to be outnumbered by this human
beings arriving and when we truly look
at the numbers so when we truly look at
the social effects that these arrivals
really made
its mostly a political construction and
it's a political construction that we
can see very well in the documentary
but with this strange couple saying
abstract things and with these men from
the popular party
because they are perfectly the
expression of uh the political effects
of this phenomenon it's uh I always
every time that I that I see again the
documentary I can't help but to have a
very mixed
feeling when this strange couple of
friends talk because at some point it
tattered in a few screenings that people
ask me if these two people they were for
real or if they were actors because at
some point it seems a bit that they are
playing a screenplay because it's it's
it's in it sounds just impossible that
they really think at some point they
might say
why are they coming from Syria there is
no warranty
and I mean being there listening to that
when he when he told us was was a bit
unobsurd so I our goal was to show
a bit this effects and to to try also to
concretely uh address
one of the main problems that as
European Union we we
[Music]
in connection with the migration
phenomenon which is
how
the political many parties of the
European political scenario used
something that is just a phenomenon is
not a problem and that concretely has no
particularly importance on the
economical political Social Development
of our countries not for bad at least
maybe it could be for good and they
transformed this phenomenon in full for
their movements and we are seeing this
everywhere in Europe and
unfortunately I had this incision that
unless something changed we will
continue to see that the future probably
not just in Europe because as human you
know very well this has been used very
similarly also in the United States
let me add another layer
which is sparked by your own comments
model
uh you link rightly
the increase in the worsening of the
situation to the Arab Spring
this is another Paradox of this debate
because they are the so-called strain
Arabs Springs or spring phenomena
because there are many different
uh
expressions of that
of that phenomenon in in the beginning
of the 2010s
they can be maybe summarily summarized
by the
finally in some countries some
democratic conscience
that has been expressed through the
people taking the streets asking for a
change of a government requesting the
change of the structure of the stage
although now the situation has worsened
the best Evolution that we saw was
Tunisia
Tunisia went through this there was a
dictator which was thrown out and then
some riots and then elections and then a
truly democratical though complicated
debate in the state and then a new
constitution now we are in a in a bad
turn I don't know how it will I I will
how it will evolved in the future but we
have to see this and where is the
contradiction in the paradox
because we sort of blame
the persons that have been liberated
by all these phenomena all these
explosions social and political
explosions for having done so and having
taken their own freedom and their own
lives in in their own hands and try to
move in places where they could have a
better life
so paradoxically we claim that we defend
democracy at home but as soon as
democracy produces
and settlement
diversions complications in the near
border the only thing we think we should
do is to put up a wall because the
people that could reap the benefit of
more democracy cannot
reach our countries so we actually
promote democracy and blame them for
every believed us at the same time
it's a terrible Paradox that brings me
back to the two lines that have read you
of the European Union treaty because if
we truly believe in human dignity and
human rights
then somewhere there must be
not a compromise but a balance between
the need of security and recognition
that human beings have a right to move
including Crossing Borders
otherwise that doesn't work our
narrative is failed
your reference to these two persons that
look like actors I think you were right
they look like actors these two persons
actually are actors in the sense that
possibly they do not truly believe in
what they say
because if they believed in it then they
should
show how
their own lives are in Conformity with
the principles that they pronounce are
invaluable I fear that we if you had had
the time to test them they would have
failed to pass that test because these
are normally people who talk about
values but do not actually
Implement them
because if they Implement being for
example a whole artist Catholic how can
they make all these people
prisoners for months with no respect on
the law
how can they push them back to Libya
it's a hell place to be without any
right there and we all know that
how
so there is a a part of acting but that
hides behind a a clear contradiction
between stated principles and actually
performance execution in practice of
those of those values that are claimed
so high is actually about about this
this human there is something that can
be somehow interesting to share because
in order to keep the documentary a bit
more balanced we to cut parts that were
much more extreme in their in their
expression basically we kept the balance
parts or what they said uh of uh I mean
there were Parts where this this uh this
man was saying that is uh political hero
is other fitted for example that we
didn't put it to the documentary because
this the idea of the documentary of all
my work and all of our work is to
to keep the documentary balanced enough
so that it's clear the the power
position but there is also enough space
for them to express themselves and we
believe that their ideas don't need
any comments because they speak for
themselves badly but we for example
decided to not push too much and to not
put for example these uh other Fiddler
declaration because we had the Sensation
that this way we would they unbalance a
bit too much the documentary we wanted
to keep to give the audience enough
about about also these two men I must
say that uh I kind of agree when you say
the time not totally sure if they truly
believe it what they say and I am not
talking about them specifically there is
a component a political component
that we can categorize as uh
nationalists far right that it's
difficult to believe that they that they
truly that it will truly uh stick to the
principles that they claim to believe in
of course they talk a lot and they do
that also in the documentary but clearly
day by day they then act you know the
way they I for example we decided to use
this part when they say that it is a
Catholic
and the and they say a lot of times this
against a bush
and that in these political discourse
there is a lot of uh
there are a lot of words for God
which when you when you think about what
is saying it sounds crazy
so he's saying you think
the worst things ever about human beings
but there is saying
that is very Catholic and we come again
there to the beach the contradiction the
human contradiction that constantly come
with this uh with people that take these
um they come from this political uh
political companies that come again from
from the effects of the phenomenon I
would like to to say something about
this last word that I say phenomenal I
also we were also discussing this about
before now clearly and we should also
say there are responsibility different
responsibilities the documentary give
some myths about where these
responsibilities lay and it is important
for me they were phenomenal because one
of the main issues is that in the last
11 years we've been talking all the time
of emergency in crisis and to use the
word problem
which is very wrong
because this is not a problem this is a
phenomenon so
one of the one of the issues is that
if we continue when if we continue to to
address this issue as a problem
we will look for a solution and of
course we will not find a solution
because this is not a problem
I I always do the example that if we
will find if we will try to do to find a
solution for rain you will never find a
solution we will continue to get out of
our apartment when it's raining and we
will continue to a brain coming glass
but if we will consider this a
phenomenon
that we will not find we will not look
for a solution we will look for
something to manage the phenomena in
case of the rain we will with a raincoat
we'll get an umbrella we will find a way
to manage the phenomena which is the
same thing that we should do with
the migration it's not a problem it's a
phenomenon it's something that always
said
always the human being is a migrant and
there's not never gonna stop and
the only goal that we are reaching by
addressing this as a problem is fooling
the political discussion that we've been
seeing in this auditory
and I have a question about another that
contradiction probably
you have this woman speaking about the
insecurity
um can you be give a bit of the
background of her because I might have
gotten that wrong but is she also one of
the I mean is she a migrant herself or
uh yeah it's a very it's a very
interesting question also the fact that
you might have uh thought that she is a
migrant but she's about this she's
speaking about this and we've been uh
we've been looking for somebody speaking
about this to put in the documentary
because again this was a clear
contradiction for what what they were
saying so basically these women was
talking against people coming from
Africa in their countries speaking a
language which is about this that
clearly sounds
because it's a mixture of different
languages where Arab in terms of sound
40 is Arabic definitely definitely as as
a pointer and uh she is part of this
nationalist organization the thoughts of
the other two men talking and uh what
air part is it's a it's a minor party
documentary but it's very
um uh is very important because
explain perfectly and graphically one of
the issues that we have in matter not
just the multimata is stronger because
it's incredible that she's being a
language which is participate and that
she also look Arabic and that she
feel this distance with
the people arriving from
countries that clearly contributed to
build the place where she lives now
you will face from
Maggie finally on my side an additional
level of complexity and
a problem that your documentary raises
so skillfully
it is the notion of Migrant we discussed
this before starting the screening
and but you're you're actually your your
work uh uh shows it perfectly well
there is this logic of
migrants as a category all these people
that come from outside are all my needs
what does that mean nobody understands
it
the only thing that defines them is that
they entered some way illegally again if
you're running at Sea and you are saved
you are not illegal
not at all
the law says the opposite
actually in Malta is very difficult to
enter the country illegally Because
unless you reach the coast with your own
boat which is very very difficult
normally you are saved at Sea and
brought to the island and in that
situation you are a legal migrant
because you are the right to be saved
then the question of what if you if you
have a right to remain in the island
that's a separate
but why is it separate because in the
discourse
the logic of Migrant control definition
hides the other one which is
ah mosques
the word mosque is repeated three or
four times
so it hides actually mostly
many of these
poor persons
come for example from Ethiopia that is a
Christian country
several people that come from Sudan are
Christians
there is a sizable minority in Egypt of
Christians
how can one simply looking at a person
that has black skin decided that is a
migrant equal to Muslim
that comes from a label that is attached
to their face
and it goes even further because they
say
this uh one of the last interviews with
this uh person young person I understand
use it
feels
Eritrean
he says they don't let me stay here
there is no future here don't try don't
try to come here because they will kill
you on the road in Libya one understands
the dangers
bits and pieces of sentences but he says
also I would like to have a family here
but I am black
so the second
unspoken reason is racism
is the color of the skin
this is the second I suppose so behind
the word migrant hides again I come back
to my
to my article of the future European
Union is the denial of your human
dignity as an individual because we
simply don't look at that person we look
at the image we think that person
projects
and if that person comes from Africa and
that person happens to be a black person
automatically that is a migrant to be
rejected because it means Muslim
and different from you
so this is what I felt very strongly so
there is in my view an urgency to fight
against this direct labeling that has
become omnipresent and is fueling the
extreme right discourse
the days
there is something that again in this in
this direction I would like to add and
it is a way a bit uh the soul of the
documentary in the documentary we try to
to work on the distance between again
the perception that the society has a
migration in the reality if we saw this
very clearly in this documentary so
there is a construction of an idea of
invasion and difference and distance and
migrants and not human being coming from
another planet while the reality is that
we are just talking of
questions human beings like us I always
make
this example which is
I don't know if you are familiar with
the geographical position of Sicily but
I will try to explain you for a moment
Sicily which is one of the saddest part
of Europe as it saw this point it's
actually Southern than Tunisia
and the difference between a person that
was born in the south of Sicily in the
president was born in Tunisia is just a
passport
it's nothing that it's not a right that
I acquired because I am particularly
intelligent or because I am uh I did
something for that I just was born in a
place that gave me a passport that gave
me the possibility to travel wherever I
was and then a person which is by both
just two hours
from my cost
as a different passport and
is her life
is a nightmare if you want to try so we
are talking about people that share the
same sea
one of these come of these areas Sicily
is a bit Southern the other one I have a
passport to give me the chance to travel
where I want
as another amount of 39 years old in
Tunisia as a much more miserable life
just because was born
a bit okay with the southern
when we think about this we realize that
our policy in terms of migration is
grounded on something that is absolutely
unacceptable which has
no Humanity at all and
when we just think about policy of
Italian governments you know many other
governments in Europe also Northern
countries yes
that don't take resolutions in order to
make this kind of
phenomenon something that is managed
with one only thing in mind which is
solidarity it's it's a kind of it's a
credibility 2022 we are still discussing
and talking about the way that we should
work in this phenomenon about what we
should do if it is clear is not
particularly complicated it's
complicated the political side maybe to
find a way but
on the omanitarian side this should not
be so complicated to understand
it's just between
slowly regain prisoners of these
perceptions of ourselves based on
nothing just because we were born in a
country instead of another which is
something that can't Define
the rights that we have it's incredible
that rights are different if you are
born in Italy or if you're born in to
this it doesn't make any sense but this
is what it is
foreign
intentions from your side
showing that because those two are like
working students
so what is it that you would like to
convey in that kind of particular scheme
especially when he's also talking about
his different people trying to contact
him to come to Malta and he's
he understand himself as someone could
not encourage you know people from there
to come he he saw well aware what how he
situated himself like he can't be too
welcoming I can also be
realistic about this isn't it
yeah
the idea first of all for example uh we
decided to not put uh in the titles the
country of origin because we didn't put
to put we didn't want to put a another
label we didn't do for all the others
people interviewed we didn't put a Italy
Malta and we didn't want to do that with
the refugees uh so this was a specific
choice that we didn't do very simple in
the other two previous documentaries the
third part of the trilogy then we the
other documentaries we decided
and uh
the idea was
to we tried we strongly tried to give an
image of the refugees as less emotional
as we could
usually in this kind of contents the
image of the refugees that we'll see
inevitably also because of the context
are very emotional are images that you
you see the documentary and sometimes
you can tell but to cry because the the
stories and the conditions are difficult
we wanted to completely change this
narrative in this documentary not
because we want to deny the other one
but because we wanted to show something
completely different that's why we we
for example you mentioned it without
working student not just Refuge because
we wanted to make clear that these are
human beings the third trying to live in
this country to study and to work at a
cost of enormous sacrifices because it's
not easy at all so the the idea was to
humanize them as much as possible trying
to put them out of this categorization
that imperatively we put them in when we
look at them in contexts like refugee
camps or when they just arrived after
three days three in the Mediterranean
but to give
to the audience the perception that
design
this is another multis then he has
hopefully these are what is working
living and that's also why we wanted to
close the documentary with this
young guy saying they actually don't
come this is difficult because again the
Reddit usually is like come it's easy
it's not like that and actually when you
when you uh when you work for a while on
the subject of migration in this part of
the world which I did now for more than
10 years you realize story of the story
that a very small minority on these
people really wanted to come to Europe
they've been forced to continue they
started to come out many times in the
documentary but I had the possibility to
experience very well
it's you Lucia was was talking a bit of
arak Springs which is of course the
let's say the historical uh a very
important historical point for for all
of these migrations again when the when
the war started Libya there are millions
of Africans from everywhere in Africa
working in Libya but they've absolutely
no interest in coming to Europe
that are working in Libya and getting
salaries the most of the times are
better than the ones that we get in
Sicily and they are not thinking at all
to come to Europe of course
to make clear I'm not defending uh
Gaddafi but this is to say that that was
a situation yeah exactly it's a fact
a lot of
mostly the people that we that arrive in
Europe and I would say I know a bit less
but I would say that probably is the
same in the United States but people
arrive in the United States will
probably prefer to just say
in that home with the family in in their
country of origin it just it's not
always possible
and this documentary this documentary
show it a bit this on from Another Side
aside to try to humanize as much as
possible the the human being
foreign
at least one maybe two of the speakers
to express an opinion that the European
Union was not sufficient in its policies
um and I write that both of those
leaders or the one that there was only
one who was in fact Maltese and not
migrant
um but it's an interesting question what
they
think should be better about European
unions
policy insofar as it exists uh and
whether what they expect to improve
should legitimately be hoped for or
whether they're just
dreaming about something that could be
better that
is realistically not likely to happen
I would say something about this and
then I will leave also to look at this
very important experience about this
actually uh one of the the I suppose
that you are talking about the women
that is speaking in Italian she is the
director of uh an NGO that is rescuing
people between uh
and uh
talking about there are many things that
European institution could do better I
will not dress one and then I will need
solution that has a lot of experience
again about this uh which is the public
convention
under this rule
which is a European Union rule when a
human being let's try to use this word
Rich Europe is allowed to ask for Asylum
just in the country of arrival and not
in another country so if a migrant
arrived in Malta can ask for a political
assignment just in mind cannot travel to
Italy or to Germany or to France or
either cannot ask for asylum in France
from malt to France from malt you can
just do that in mind
this is
a huge problem for
many reasons first of all because of
course the southern countries of Europe
they've a disorder this proportionate
amount of responsibility in comparison
with the northern countries of Europe
but also because mostly of course the
human beings arriving don't want to stay
in this other part of Europe but would
like to go in the northern part of
Europe and uh
and also because in the specific case of
Malta and you can probably imagine that
very easily most of the human beings
arriving in Malta they don't know what
matter is of course they talk about
further North Africa
thinking they will reach Europe and they
end in malt which is a very small island
in the middle of the video they did not
it existed they didn't know it's a
country
it's can you imagine they they they're
stuck they basically can't move from
there they can go anywhere else they can
either get an asylum political
assignment there or go back which had
another layer of problems to what they
say and they will need to we should
definitely have something to say about
this in schools
maybe I will I would try to be
systematic but short because this is a
huge question you are raising actually
first you said in so far as there is a
policy don't get be don't be mistaken
there is a policy Europe the European
Union has deployed a significant
force of protection of the Border called
frontex
which is very very powerful it is
mentioned in the documentary frontex
what is frontex frontex is a
quasi-federalized agency
that complements the control of the
external voters of the Union in the
areas that have particular difficulties
that are now widespread because with the
recent Belarus crisis then we have it in
the baltics we have them down in in
Bulgaria versus Turkey we have them in
Greece we have them in Italy and Malta
and now also in the Canary Islands
because of the crossings from Morocco
so you see that this is now spread
around we are talking about numbers that
are becoming serious we're over 10 000
men and women
permanently employed and they have a
couple of billions of viewers available
which is equal to a couple of billions
of dollars so although it's not huge
numbers it becomes a serious number
and that makes a difference they are
patrolling they dispose of the best
equipment in terms of of satellite
control
they use the same kind of satellite
systems that the military and the Navy
of NATO uses in Mediterranean they're
sharing the same kind of equipment
so they are extremely Sophisticated
close to what you see with the homeland
security that has been developed here
so that was not existent 10 years ago
the sacrosanct protection of the of the
frontiers of your country that was
considered by the Patriots to be in for
the countries you know European union
nothing to do no
all the extremists or less extremists of
Europe are now behind the existence of a
federal European Union policy concerned
with frontex
but when it comes to a federal
quasi-federal approach to the influx of
these human beings that is generically
labeled as migrants then there it
disappears
why because the main drive there is what
you've heard in this documentary
foreign
means protection of your culture
protection of your Customs protection of
your religion hence each States keeps it
to itself
so the
the the the doubling
the doubling treaty or doubling
agreement which is now translated into
European Union regulations
it's actually very Progressive in terms
of Asylum seeking rights
there is a wealth of
legislation that is actually very
Progressive
and I
can stay without exaggerating that it is
one of the most Progressive in the world
the problem is the limitation that Mauro
is indicating
so what is lacking is exactly that
Crossing
we like having a federalized police at
the border we don't like having a
federalized
policy of Distributing the people
because the problem is not with the
moment when you disembark
somebody should know that if that person
is embarrassing Malta it's Malta taking
care of the identification
and providing or not the status of
refugee for example all right that could
be perfectly okay provided that Malta is
not stuck with all these people that do
not go anywhere
so the redistributions and
redistribution hits the wall of this
kind of discourse that you have heard in
the documentary
yes and I unfortunately have to say is
the same debate that you have here in
the United States identity I can mention
one person although I don't know if this
is kosher enough or not but if I
mentioned Mr Bannon Steve Bannon you may
have heard of him
former Aid of Mr Trump he was pursuing
the same policies in Europe throughout
he is called as a guru by certain quotas
in European politics politics
there is a clear direct connection even
through the same persons on the two
sides of the Atlantic so we are
confronted to a generational
cultural and air therefore political
issue here
and sorry to come back to my starting
point of this change
human dignity and human rights an
individual
we cannot dispose of groups of people
undefined as migrants and keep them like
Parcels in a in a in a in a warehouse
somewhere in one country or the other
and then we need to solve
we must solve
it's unsustainable
can I follow up so what happened when
they are in
in Malta so we were talking about like
the government stuff that's been wrong
not there and then so I just thought
this is what happens what happened after
that for people yeah but what happens
before also because if you are in Malta
and you're stuck with all these people
the question that you are asking is what
happens next if I am an asylum seeker
and I am given Asylum status because in
my country it I cannot go back
Eritrea and Ethiopia I mean
Sudan a clear examples you kind of push
these people back not only it's inhuman
it's in violation of existing convention
International conventions like the
refugee Convention of the 1951 of the UI
no so
we cannot do so Malta is stuck with
these people they must keep them
so what is the alternative for Malta
push back as many as possible because we
we heard that as again we cannot get
more
which is
not entirely correct because
this is a perception we are full full of
what that is full of requests of people
working and doing jobs that nobody takes
in most as much as in Italy and
elsewhere
but this idea that if we open up
the working opportunities
here I come with a with the word then
you open up to a cool Factor this is the
word in politics in Europe and also in
this state
in this in this country
pool factor meaning you actually incite
people to come because they will find
work
so you don't give them anything
so that it shows exemplarly that you
will it's useless to come so what
happens is before and after after you
keep them completely separated to make
it an example for the outside and before
you make it sure that you take them the
least possible including you
one creates problems to the ngos that
save people at sea
in this case I was involved it had this
its judgment the first of August was
exactly about that Italy putting all
possible obstacles to the ngos that save
people let's see why because by doing
that the pull factor is diminished
people should know that if they try to
cross they will die so they don't come
nothing of that neither before nor after
seems to me in line with the principles
they are not
I think it is objective it is not a
simple perception
towards something which is very uh banal
but I think again we come back to the
same to the same image it's important to
to
exist you asked what happened when they
when they after their their lives
basically one thing which is one one
more time
absurd uh there is an officer at some
point deciding if this human being
traveled to Malta as the colonial
migrant
was an ascended Series so there is
somebody from an office deciding this
there will be an interview and they will
leave and check if he is cars if you
have a psychological uh situation that
might be related to some kind of
violence you suffered in your country of
origin and then after this interview and
after the review of your psychological
case your physical case the country
you're coming they will decide okay you
are traveling here because
there is a problem in your country or
you're telling here just because you
want a better future
the second case we are denied Asylum of
course
because to want a better future is not
enough to cut here
in the first case if you clearly show
signs of
problems from your country of origin
then you might be
allowed to stay with a status of refugee
which then leads again to
all the complications because when you
when you got your Refugee status this
was important that we this would be a
very long discussion because sometimes
we hate this Sensation that okay you got
your Refugee status now your life is
Paradise
is not exactly also the review status
actually does that is not guaranteeing a
very necessarily a happy life it's good
it's a good it's a good way to start
unless you're the right to stay Europe
but still there are a lot of limitation
and a lot of uh
criteria that you continuously need to
uh for a female to stay
okay so thank you very much to both of
you
um visiting fellow at the European
studies Council and to Mauro Mondello
for your
discussions very fruitful discussions
that we had on the topic and I hope then
to be able to to have you back at
another opportunity with your thoughts
thank you thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]